hello my name is jason lomuler and i'm
an assistant professor in the department
of surgery and immunology at the
university of pittsburgh and my lab
works on engineering chimeric antigen
receptor t cells for cancer therapy and
today i'm going to tell you about some
of our work
on engineering universal carb therapy
and so for a brief outline first i'm
going to go over background of car t
cell therapy and then an introduction to
universal car t cells as well as the
universal snap car t cells that my lab
is working on
and then i'm going to go into new
directions with universal car t cells
universal syn notch cells as well as
conditional control of universal car t
cells
and so first off
the general area that we're working on
is an area called adoptive t-cell
therapy for cancer and the way this
therapy works is that a patient goes
into the clinic and their
pbmcs or peripheral blood mononuclear
cells are harvested
and then t cells are isolated and then
engineered
to either make a car or a tcr protein
and again my lab works on and car
engineered t cells
and then the patient undergoes host
conditioning chemotherapy and then the
the car t cells are introduced into the
patient to have some kind of anti-tumor
activity in the patient
and so what are car t cells so car t
cells are again the patient's t cells
that are engineered to make a car
protein or a chimeric antigen receptor
this protein has
three general components
it has an antigen binding scfe which
recognizes the target protein or antigen
on the tumor cell
and then it has different t cell
signaling domains within the
intracellular part of the
car
and upon binding to the tumor antigen
the car will become activated and lead
to
tumor cell lysis and also production of
things like cytokines or other gene
program responses
and there's a lot of excitement about
this therapy mainly because of the
dramatic results that have been seen in
the clinic with um hematological
malignancies there are now five fda
approved car t cell therapies four of
those are targeting the cd19 protein on
different b-cell cancers and then the
newest
is targeting the protein bcma
also on hematological malignancies and
this original fda approval was based on
really dramatic results with patients
who had
who had failed standard therapy
who normally have only a seven percent
five year survival rate with car t cell
therapy these patients now had over 83
percent complete responses
so in the clinic
the first two car t cell therapies that
were approved were kim ryan and yes
carter again they had really
exciting results because as you can see
here this is these are survival plots
of progression-free survival
over a time and you can see that even at
24 months post therapy about half the
patients are completely cancer free
and again this is much better than
traditional therapy however
there are still 60 percent of patients
or so who are not responding and so what
my lab is working on is trying to
address this 60
of patients who are not responding
and so what are the reasons for that
lack of response
so there are several uh limitations that
have now been discovered in terms of why
the therapy is not working for those
patients
and so
one of the original ones is that carb
failure can happen
at the product manufacturing phase so
patients can have t cells that won't
expand enough or they will have limited
persistence in the patients
another mechanism is having antigen
modulation so the patient's cancers can
actually lose the target lose the
targeted antigen either cd19 or cd20
and
or it could get um down modulated on the
surface so that car t cells are no
longer able to target those cancers
and then next there can also be
toxicities from the therapy being so
potent that will actually lead to
cytokine
responses that become toxic to other
tissues
and then finally there's a great unmet
need in treating other types of cancer
so currently these are working for
leukemias but solid tumors really make
the majority of the cancer
burden
around the world
and so to address these um these
shortcomings mylab and others are
working on developing universal car
t-cells and so what is a universal car
instead of it it's a car t cell where
instead of binding directly to a tumor
antigen the car
t cells are co-administered with these
tumor
targeting adapters or two anti-tumor
antibodies
and
the way the car works is that instead of
binding directly the tumor it binds to
the tag on the antibody and then the
antibody binds to the tumor cell and so
why do this
so this therapy potentially has several
advantages over current therapy
one of these is that there can be
tunable activity so instead of dosing in
different numbers of t cells what we can
do is we can dose in different amounts
of the
adapter that anti-tumor tagged antibody
and in dosing it more slowly you could
potentially avoid toxicity
from
by ramping up the amount of the
tumor activity anti-tumor activity in
the patients
this also allows the clinician to target
multiple different antigens or proteins
on the same tumor cell by applying
different anti uh tumor antibodies with
the universal car t cells
as you can see here in this diagram
and then finally there's it's also very
exciting because this universal car t
cell could be used not only for
hematological malignancies but also for
solid tumors
simply by combining the universal car t
cells with different anti-tumor adapters
and so it's a highly versatile therapy
compared to traditional therapy
and so again this is how the therapy
would work
so the patient um the patient's blood
cells are isolated and then transduced
with a virus to make the universal car
those cells are then expanded and then
reinfused back into the patient
and then at the same time
um the patient is administered with that
anti-tumor adapter molecule and this
again gives control over um
more control over the the timing of the
therapy as well as the potency as uh the
anti-tumor activity
and
to date um
there have been several anti uh
anti-tumor universal cartes cell
therapies developed and the different
variations really come in the type of
adapter that's being used with a therapy
as well as the targeting molecule on the
car so you can see here they fall into
four generic categories and i'm going to
tell you about a fifth one that we're
developing
in our lab so this first one is taking a
an antibody that has a natural binding
partner on the immune receptor and so
in this case the tag protein is
recognizing a biotin molecule that's
attached to the antibody adapter and
then that antibody recognizes the
antigen on the tumor cell
then there are also anti-tag cars which
recognize other tag molecules placed on
the adapter molecule
as well as uh by specific
engaging immune receptors and then adcc
mediating immune receptors which target
the constant region on the antibody
adapter molecule
and so what we're working on my in on in
my lab is developing universal snap car
t cells and so these are slightly
different from those uh other adapter
cards in uh that i went over on the last
page and so the way this works is our
car has as the targeting molecule
uh the protein snap
and this is a human enzyme that's
engineered to react with benzyl guanine
it's a benzyl guanine tag that goes on
the adapter molecule and what makes this
really unique is that instead of simply
binding to the tag the way that snap
works is it will
actually perform a chemical reaction
with the adapter and form a covalent
bond with the antibody adapter
and so when the antibody is administered
um it will form this covalent
interaction and then it can sense the
antigen and lead to t cell activation
and effector functions
and so
what we do in the lab is we conjugate
the
benzyl guanine
tag to the antibody and we've done this
to several different
anti-tumor antibodies targeting a
variety of antigens and these are all
different clinically approved antibodies
that are currently
in use and you can see we're targeting
antigens like cd19 and cd20 which are
found on blood cancers as well as egfr
and her2 which are found on
solid tumors
again hoping to find that this will be a
universal
programmable therapy
and so uh what we did was we we made a
lentiviral dna construct encoding the
snap car
and then we
packaged it into lentivirus and we
transduced primary human t cells um with
the construct
and again we have that snap tag domain
which forms the covalent bond with the
adapter and then we
made the rest of the car with the hinge
domain of the from the cd8 protein as
well as the 401 bb and cd3 zeta
cell signaling domains and we're using a
blue fluorescent protein as a marker for
cells that were transduced with the with
the car
and you can see here on the right flow
cytometry plots where we see efficient
car expression in the t cells so you can
see on the x-axis tag bfp expression as
well as
on the y-axis staining with a snap
surface dye
and this is compared with
cells that were not transduced with the
virus
and so next we wanted to see can we use
these snap car t cells
and
um different anti-tumor antibodies
labeled with the benzoyl guanine to
retarget um car t-cell activity against
different cancer cell lines plus and
minus these different tumor antigens and
so we mix the tumor cells and the t
cells
together as well as the different
anti-tumor adapters and we acade for
interferon gamma production and you can
see here that we only saw significant
interferon gamma production when we had
matched
antigen and antibody combinations so
here we're targeting cd20
and then next egfr
as well as both her2 and egfr
on an ovarian cancer cell line
and next after this we want to see can
we actually lyse tumor cells using these
universal car t cells in adapters and so
in this case we assayed for two
different outputs we looked at um one
marker
for
t cell
anti-tumor activity which is cytotoxic
granular release the marker cd107a
becomes upregulated on the t cells
and again we see a pattern in which only
when we have the matched antibody
and antigen
combination
do we have upregulation of cd107a
and then we actually looked at lysis of
tumor cells
and here
again we only see significant lysis of
the cells when we have
matched antigen
and antibody
tumor targeting specificity
okay and then
to
really show off the in
examine the
um
universality of the therapy we wanted to
see could we use the therapy to actually
at the same time
target multiple antigens so this would
be what we'd want to do to try to avoid
um cancer relapse due to antigen loss so
if a tumor has both for instance cd20
and egfr can we use both antibodies and
efficiently target
the
both antigens at the same time to avoid
that loss
or if we had a tumor with pre-existing
variation where some cells only had cd20
and some had only egfr could we
eliminate
all of those cells in addition to the
ones that have both
and so what we did was we mixed or we we
first again we're looking at specific
lysis so this is killing of
um
cd20 tumor cells using the rituximab
with bg as well as egfr expressing cells
that have
killing of those using a cytoxama with
bg we see very efficient and specific
killing
using those antibodies on the single
cell populations and then when we mix
the cells alone what we see is this on
the top plot we have the killing
of only the egfr cells and so when we
add in cytosumab alone we see efficient
killing of those cells but not of the
cd20 positive cells on the bottom plot
and similarly when we
add in rituximab which targets cd20 we
only see significant lysis of the cd20
positive rawgi cells
but not of the egfr cells and when we
combine both antibodies we see very
very efficient killing of both target
cell populations so in indeed this could
be a good therapy to target multiple
antigens at the same time
and so for next steps we're moving the
therapy uh we're advancing our
development of the therapy to testing in
animal models and i'm not going to go
over those experiments today but i do
want to briefly cover the
the current
status of universal car t cell therapies
as they're moving to the clinic so now
as i mentioned there are several groups
who are developing
universal car therapies and they are
moving to the clinic and here you can
see
um
several of the different technologies
and their current status and i want to
include this
also as just a general reference
but there are several
trials being undertaken targeting
different blood cancers as well as now
some solid tumors um using trastuzumab
targeting her too
and so these are very exciting and
we hope to
advance the snapcar t-cell therapy also
to trials in the near future
so in general
there are several
pros to
car t cell therapy but there are also
some limitations and i just wanted to
review those here so the pros are that
universal cards can target multiple
antigens in the same tumor in order to
potentially prevent relapse because you
can combine the universal car t cells
with multiple adapters to target
different antigens at the same time and
so if if the cells lost cd19 you could
also be targeting cd20 at the same time
for instance
you could also use the same car t cells
for both a
hematological malignancy as well as a
solid tumor just by combining them with
different adapters and finally um we can
also control activity by dosing in
different amounts of the adapter
and so for the cons
so it is a more complex therapy so of
course
the therapy now consists of both the
cell component and some other adapter
component so that could be more
complicated for regulatory reasons um
but in general um
as we're using already approved
antibodies i think that's less of a
concern there's also some concern with
tumor penetration using adapters um
because you also need the adapters to
potentially penetrate the tumor as well
as the t cells and we're hoping with the
snapcar t cells as they're covalently
labeling the t cells that um this would
be less of an issue because um the tumor
trafficking of the t cells
the t cells can be pre-labeled by the
antibody and then traffic to the tumor
okay and so now i'm going to switch
gears into some next directions that we
are undertaking with universal car
t-cell therapy
and so
the first is
has to do with a new variety of
engineered receptor uh
this is work out of uh wendell lim's lab
and ucsf as well as cold royal in
developing these syn notch receptors and
so a traditional car
upon binding to an antigen will activate
t cell effector functions um like
cytokines interferon gamma and target
cell killing but the way that syn notch
receptors work is that they will sense
an antigen and then activate any gene or
genes of interest in response so it's a
much more programmable kind of designer
gene response that they can make
and so the cool thing about this is that
you can engineer t cells that would
locally deliver
a specific payload instead of simply
focusing on killing the tumor cells
maybe
a better idea is to have them
help out
other things such as
well different other therapeutic agents
which could either have anti-tumor
function or could be used for other
types of diseases
as well as controlling the fate of the t
cell
and also stimulating endogenous immunity
so can you make um some molecules that
will activate other immune cells to have
uh anti-disease function
and so what we wanted to do uh was
uh could we see if we could make uh
t cells that had universal syn notch
receptors to provide some of the
benefits of the universal cars to the
syn notch receptor technology
and
so again this is the way the synod
receptor works
so it takes a novel environmental input
and leads to a novel transcriptional
output and so what happens is upon
binding to
the target antigen
the receptor will get pulled and then
cleaved and released a transcription
factor to turn on the designer gene
program and so what we wanted to do was
create one using the snap protein so we
made a
snap snin notch receptor that we would
combine with benzoyl guanine tagged
after the antibody adapters
and then lead to a covalently assembled
receptor
and then
downstream also in the same cell we have
a response gene uh which has a promoter
sensitive to the transcription factor
and then an output gene in this case
we're using
tag vfp blue fluorescent protein
and so upon antigen binding the receptor
will get cleaved leading to production
of that output gene
and so if indeed
when we add
these receptors to t cells
and we combine them with or without the
adapter on the left we have an anti-cd19
adapter and we uh have them either with
cd19 positive or cd19 negative cells and
we assay for tag dfp expression we see
that we are able to redirect um snap sin
notch activity
to produce the output bfp protein only
in response to antibody adapter and
antigen on the targeted cells
and we can also do this using an
anti-cd20 adapter
the rituximab adapter again seeing only
response when we have
um
the cd20 positive cell
so this is very exciting and now we're
working on uh applying this technology
to lead to production of therapeutic
gene outputs to try to enhance car t
cell therapy using these engineered
synaptic receptors
and so now i'm going to tell you about
another new direction that we're we're
looking at and this is
applying conditional control to the
universal car therapy and we're looking
at um both uh two different types of off
switch
control mechanisms and so one of these
is can we use light to actually
control the car t cell technology so can
we make a car t cell that is
controlled by light to actually avoid an
anatomical site in the body
and
so here you can see we have a brain
which
uh has a tumor on one part but maybe we
know that the car that we're going to be
using or the antibody has some
off-target activity on another region of
the brain so we need can we
create
control where we can shine light on that
part of the
organ and then protect it from car t
activity
and then also could we create a system
that maybe would have systemic toxicity
but that we could tune it or switch it
off if we see that toxicity in the
patient using a small molecule
and so
we have a collaboration with the dieters
lab in chemistry trying to develop this
and they're experts at creating uh
conditional chemistry control and we
have um
because we're adding this benzoyl
guanine
to the adapter we're already using
chemistry
this is actually a great venue to try
out these reactive chemistries to try to
get conditional control and so the way
this will work is we'll take our
traditional adapter but instead of being
connected having the benzyl guanine
connected by an inert linker it will
have a reactive linker that will either
get cleaved by light stimulation or by a
small molecule addition and so when the
adapter is present and it has um
no stimulus attached it will act like
any other adapter and activate uh snap
cartier cell activity but when light or
the small molecule are applied it will
cleave that benzyl green guanine off and
won't lead to any signaling by the
therapeutic t cells
okay and so um
working with the dieter's lab we created
these
cleavable offswitch adapter
where um
it's reactive to blue light so when the
blue light
is applied to the system it will cut off
the um the tag molecule on the adapter
and so we combined the
the off switch adapters with the
universal car t cells as well as the
target cells and then we applied light
for different amounts of time and you
and then acid for tumor cell lysis and
what you can see on the right
um is that if we had traditional car t
cells um in green and blue
if we um
applied
them to tumor cells they were unaffected
by light stimulus
and if we also used a an adapter that
had an inert peg 2 linker which is our
standard linker
in orange it also was not affected by
light but when we used our light
cleavable
adapters at two different concentrations
we saw that we get
induced
suppression of the
tumor cell lysis and so we were able to
con
turn off
lysis using the light for these two
adapter antibodies and in even at 10
seconds of light exposure uh we already
saw a dramatic reduction in near
complete and
reduction by 45 seconds of exposure
and so for the the clinic the real
excitement comes to applying this
where light is already being used which
is in fluorescence guided surgery so
currently
there are some systems which in which
patients are applied with a fluorescent
contrast agent and this helps to
visualize the tumors in the patients
um
and
help guide the surgeons who are who are
performing treatment and so um what
we're trying to do is to also create uh
cleavable or activatable linkers that
are reactive to um other wavelengths of
light
so in the near infrared wavelengths to
hopefully use them in this
type of uh therapy
so we also
built a drug controlled off switch and
in this case we're using a small
molecule drug
phosphine uh
called 2d pbm
and what we can see on the right is that
if we add the drug and the adapter at
different concentrations
to
um tumor cells and then we we stain for
adapter signaling on the z-axis you can
see we can get very tunable control of
the amount of tag on the surface of the
tumor cells
and then similarly when we go to
look for
control of car t cell
tumor cell killing we also see we get
very nice tunable control over car t
cell function
and you can see again if we have
inert linkers the peg two linkers
or a traditional
car
we don't see any reduction from the
small molecule being added to the
to the co-culture but if we do if we
have our cleavable linkers we see that
nice reduction
and it's
close to the
no adapter control
and so for the next steps with the
conditional control technology we're
also very interested in creating on
switches
and i think
our general excitement here is that we
can provide even more control and more
tumor specificity
using conditional control and so
um we have a few different control
stimuli that we're especially interested
in and um the first of these is again
using light
and
the really nice thing about using light
as an on switch is that instead of
protecting some anatomical location we
could actually use light to direct
the activity so if we have an
unregulated car t cell therapy in which
there's
a specific tumor site that we know we
want to hit but we're worried about on
target toxicity on in the rest of the
organ we can apply light only to the
specific tumor site and get activity
only in that region
and similarly
with
a small molecule triggered system
we could
wait we could apply the adapter
antibodies systemically wait for it to
collect at the tumor site and then apply
the small molecule drug um systemically
to the patient to get
tuned activity and local activity
and lastly we're also developing
switches
that are controlled by uh tumor micro
environment stimuli so
in addition to making different target
antigens the tumor microenvironment is
known to have different chemical
conditions
including acidosis so lower ph
expression of different proteases
which also help tumor cells to
metastasize such as mmps or legumine and
then
reactive oxygen species
like hydrogen peroxide and so the idea
is can we get greater tumor specificity
by engineering adapters that are decaged
or activated upon these stimuli being
added um and again so
we have our adapter that now has the
benzel guanine but this red cage on it
and when we apply these different
stimuli
they will lead to decaging of that
benzoyl guanine and then activation of
the snap receptor signaling
and so
this is where we're headed and i think
it's these types of
advancements that will lead to universal
car t cell therapy being applied to many
more types of cancer and
ultimately
making a dent in the cancer epidemic
and so with that i want to acknowledge
my lab
and everyone who contributed to the
project and our
many collaborators and
our current and past funding support
and also thank you for your attention